so
hello and welcome to the power of omics
my name is madalina oppermann i am the
director of applications for
sales support in chromatography and mass
spectrometry
emi at thermal future scientific
i will be your moderator for today's
event the three webinar sessions of
today
are part of a special event we are
running this
year in advance of the international
super connect meeting
and they will be outlining the power of
proteomics in key application areas
this event will discuss how scientists
are harnessing the power of proteomics
to advance scientific research
and each day you will hear first from
our plenary speakers
in the opening session they are followed
by selected scientists
in the second daily session scientists
will provide
an overview of the current state of
research
in their individual fields daily
the third session will feature a
roundtable discussion
led by a prominent researcher
providing a look towards the future
and giving you the opportunity to join
in what we all hope
will be a very interactive and
interesting discussion
yesterday we were tackling bruce
research
and the and expanding on the theme of
why we need proteomics to complement
genomics
addressing how virus research drives the
knowledge
and the development of vaccines and
diagnostics
tomorrow we will take another leap we
will be
going beyond and unleashing the power of
proteomics
today the focus is proteomics and cancer
a new perspective the promise of
proteomics in the study of cancer
has been with us for a long time now
we have witnessed a number of
breakthroughs
advances in technology in applications
have significantly improved
our condition and our understanding
enabling a deeper perception
and understanding of cancer phenotypes
protein-based knowledge offers insights
that are directly actionable
as they could be potential biomarkers or
therapeutic targets
latest proteomics technologies and
workflows are emerging
as high throughput comprehensive
quantitative targeted enabling cancer
proteomics to
complement genetic information
the session includes areas
to study various aspects of
cancer disease encompassing cancer
pathway proteomics
proteogenomics immunopeptidomics
as well as examples of standardization
across laboratories
making data gathering a major effort
and a cop and providing
comprehensiveness
of outcomes with the research community
driving proteomics to realize its
full potential for cancer prevention
diagnostics and treatment we will also
feature a roundtable session focused on
the need to maximize information
from a proteomic dataset that can
deliver
faster insights with almost no
errors to help accelerate
a search to biomarkers or monitor
therapies for their effectiveness
so without any further delay i would
like to turn over the floor to our first
presenter
to professor demarco varga from the
university of lund
whom we have to the pleasure to have as
our invited speaker
for the plenary session professor marco
varga all
over to you
okay so thank you for the kind
introduction so
today i would like to tell you about the
um
an ongoing activity we have in a
collaborative effort with the nih
in a partnership in the us
where we have established the european
cancer moonshot here in lund sweden
so it's actually linked to a a
healthcare area region in southern
sweden with 10 hospitals
and also we are collaborating in a
multi-center approach globally
with tokyo and also with
seoul in korea as well as semelbais
and seget hospital in in hungary
so in this effort i would like to show
you
uh the activity that we have right now
on going in the european cancer moonshot
and
so we are also engaged
together with professor
malm where we are in the governmental
team setting the activities for cancer
moonshots
in sweden in in collaborative effort
on a national basis with nih so that
work is ongoing right now and there will
be focus to certain
cancer areas
um so here i show you sort of
some views of of where we built the
the european cancer moonshot and that is
um
within the biomedical center so it's
located within the hospital area
that is quite extensive inland so
that's on the the left-hand side photo
and then
on the right hand lower photo you can
see the the the big block building
so like 800 beds and then on top of that
this colorful building is actually the
the radiology center where we
quite newly established where they have
uh really frontline
uh treatment for for cancer patients
the team in lund is very international
so we are like uh all in all 40
scientists and
we come from 15 different countries
uh and it's very much sort of a build
of this team where we
focus on scientists a few of us
we sort of reached 50 plus and then
to use the experience of these somewhat
older scientists
many of these are have experience from
pharma industry or biotech industry and
then
to link that with the young excited
scientists postdocs and researchers who
come to us either in collaborative
efforts
or via the centers that we
collaborate with or just by ad hoc if we
meet up or they contact us and they they
come over
for a shorter or a longer period stay
now the recent
joint effort we have is with brazil i'm
very excited about so we we partnered in
we with brazil
and we have uh research activities
clinical studies uh
phd students as well as senior
scientists and also
we have a genomic center
in rio de janeiro where we do
joint efforts in in different study
activities so this is a newly
established part
now within the european cancer moonshot
activity
we put a very strong emphasis on
outreach and i mean outreach to the
to society to the population and so we
would like to
build cancer awareness and the whole
idea
is also that we would like to have since
we
have the patient in the center uh it's
also
very often the case that involves that
it involves
relatives family and friends
so usually the patient is not alone
however the patient is in the center and
we
we consider then that the research area
of resource as well as the healthcare
the hospitals
are actually in order to provide
support and care and find solutions
for the patient so in this way we
we work this together we work together
with different organizations
to build this further as we go along
now i'm going to show you a few
parts here where this is an open house
event that we
did and this was like half a day from
lunch to
to early evening and here you see the
biomedical center building
and then on the right hand side you see
you see the
the the big block and also
you see clinical chemistry over here
pharmacology
and what we did here was to invite
uh anybody who wanted to attend
and we actually got quite a lot of
young people from society and also from
high schools we had
athletes from from sports clubs
we also had a swimming team with like
80 swimmers who came along to make a
visit
and all the post docs and and young
scientists they were out in the labs
demonstrating and showing what's going
on and what's actually
happening at the european cancer push
center
so i put together a few uh slides here
of photos
from this open house event and on the
left-hand side here you can see
that on the lower part we have
ichtvan who is the dermatologist and
pathologist who
and then makes a mole testing on one of
the visitors the girl here and making a
a picture and then uses a software tool
developed
in order to investigate the the
properties of the mole and whether
there are any signs of of possible
malignancy
early early indications so this is how
we demonstrate the technology
development and how
we actually are able to to work together
now um above you see uh this man with
the
inhaler uh it's not an inhaler sorry
it's a uh
it's a device for for long volume
measurement so it's a spirometry
and uh he's actually a lung cancer
patient
it it turned out and also we had that
demonstration so you can actually follow
the curve of
of inhale and exhale volume long volume
and thereby you can make readouts
whether there are any particular
problems with with alarm compartments so
uh in the upper uh part you can see
uh the lamps that we have so this you
recognize so these
these are um aspects labs where we do
all the
um protein analysis sequencing
uh some very interested uh visitor who
checked out that can you really measure
these small volumes here it's incredible
and then on the lower end here on the
right
it's actually marcel from from symbol
vice that uh
makes a a live demo of not like but a
demo of
pathology where he's using digital
pathology
in order to be able to identify
different
clones of cancer cells within the tumor
so all of this is really to try to
understand how the disease
presents itself and when you do that
then you can also
further see the um the actual battle
in between uh the invader so the cancer
cells
and then the defense system that is our
immune
immune system and this is what we are
then focusing on trying to understand
mechanisms that drive the the cancer
development
now if we look to the
stage from early very early indication
until uh stage four and mortality
uh there is a clear development of of
how the
this this happens in uh in
melanoma
development uh for for malignancy in
patients and
usually what you see is that you get
some
uh mole that that sort of grows or or
has another
shape or or or color so there is an
abcde
uh way of classifying that and then we
also participated
uh in the who new classification
uh setting that has been made that's the
the eighth
of that we then align with and we
characterize all the tumors based upon
that
and then you you move usually you can
have
a from the primary what you then find is
that you get a development
of of metastases uh
spread and that is usually uh can be
lymph nodes
uh development that is most common and
then it can also
progress to to next stage of stage three
where you you see more and more uh grow
of the size of the lymph nodes and then
in stage three
usually you get a much more
aggressive uh metastasis spread
it can happen through vascularization or
it can also
happen by other means but but the main
thing here is that you
you will um end up with uh
where you have metastases and tumors
uh of uh melanoma
in the lung uh and in the brain so
usually there's stage four
and actually very few percentage of of
those patients actually make it
and can have a longer survival from that
stage
so these are our our parts that we
divide in
the patient groups and also we
investigate
drug treatment so the impact of drugs
and how
the patient change in terms of disease
presentation
um so here is an example i took
um from from a publication
some time ago where you can see um
with drug treatment where you have very
efficient
breakdown of tumor development so you
see here in between
the left hand um images or
photos of of this man from
front and back and you also can see
after 15 weeks of targeted
treatment with personalized medicine of
the impact of
of how improvements are made so there
are
there are quite some uh new developments
especially also on immunotherapy that is
showing a very good progress um
and then we will allude to how that goes
about now
if you think about a patient uh that you
see on this slide
i i made a way so
usually what you find throughout a life
span
of a disease a disease of mold so
in the very left corner here you have
some
cells that have been activated by
by mutations different type of mutations
and these are
the drivers of of of tumor growth
and usually what happens is that you
come into the hospital
the patient does and then from that
diagnosis
you actually uh start to grow uh the
primary tumor
and that's when you when you notice so
by some sort of imaging technology
ct or mri this is then manifested and
then
what you do is then you you uh make a
um isolation of the tumor and usually
uh and make a treatment impact so it can
be by drugs and surgery or surgery alone
and usually what happens is that the
tumor burden comes down
so then this this tumor is manifested
and then
some period of time elapse so typically
uh three two to nine months or even some
patients can go several years but then
somehow after treatment uh this act this
tumor even though
you have seen on the ct that the tumor
burden is zero
that means that the entire tumor has
disappeared
uh it will come back so there will be a
resistance
build or a a
a new relapse and then what you will see
is that you will come up with a new
more intense tumor development and then
the you you
and the blue arrow indicates uh an
action by the hospital
and then it goes down again but then
you're in a phase where you actually
have
repeated recurrence and and in the end
this actually
will bring in most cases uh the patient
to mortality
so they will not make it so so what we
are
mostly managing to do here is is to
prolong life
on this patient in many cases so the
golden rule is the earlier we can
indicate the earlier we can find it the
higher chance
so in the beginning you have like 90
percent chance of making in stage one
when you come to stage four you have
less than ten
so it's its own indication is really
important okay so if you go from here to
uh some of the the factors that actually
impacts on whether you're gonna get
malignancy or not
it's not really fully understood but it
is related to
to um to heritage
uh there is a genetic heritage but also
that you have during your lifetime a um
a change and a mutation of genes that
then
will alter also uh improtimitation
and and that is where uh drugs are
developed in order to
to address the the the protein
regulation
and um exactly how this comes about is
not really known
however based upon
the weinberg principle we do know that
in in most uh cancers you have
uh key regulating genes and proteins
so and these are the the the drivers
now the drivers themselves are key
in in driving the the growth of the
tumor and also the proliferation
so that means that um they cannot manage
alone so they need
sort of uh passengers so the passengers
are the one
that is is helping the drivers to move
the
the proliferation and the growth and
also to drive
the tumor into metastases um
i have listed here uh braf and rasa kita
etc and also the the passengers
these are the most commonly well known
for for melanoma and so
what we do with this is that we have now
the genes identified and we are
currently looking into the
to the protein expression and and then
how these uh
counterparty
come together and whether there is an
absolute overlap
of the gene uh mutation expression
in the protein and what we have found is
that this is actually not the case
so here i show you um a few
images and and pictures of
patients that we exemplified by patients
that we
isolate by surgical intervention smaller
early tumors like up in the left-hand
side
and also examples of other
in in the face and also on other places
of the body
and also uh on the right side here you
see also that there are is an example of
a
75 year old patient
who during a 10 year period
actually got local reoccurrence on the
leg
that looked like not harmful at all but
then eventually
actually made made
the situation worse and and could not be
handled so this patient
passed away 10 years later to the
right-hand side you see a
it's it's a young male who
who also came into the clinic uh
where they found first some some moles
in the beginning with focal
and also later they were
able to manifest the dissemination of
the disease and you see
uh that this patient also had like seven
six seven years
uh of development and then passed away
and you see that there are metastases
spread
throughout the the head and neck part
that is quite severe
so these are common cases in these
patients so when you look to these
different situations of these patients
and we do do
quite high numbers so we do hundreds and
hundreds of these patients on a
yearly basis we did a small
pilot where we looked at primary tumors
we looked at the expression of lymph
node metastases
tumors and also primary
melanoma cells that were isolated and
then
we looked for the comparison of protein
expression and these are
in the reach range of six to seven
thousand proteins
uh and if you do a um a computation of
this
uh you will see on the right hand side
that
the the red ones the primary term is
actually pretty
spread out so they are more dis alike
uh while on the other hand friends if
you look to the cell line they are
pretty much
similar having uh commonly uh
distributed expression of proteins
while the lymphos are are also a little
bit similar to
but but still still they are or are
grouped together and typically when you
isolate
cells i mean they they will then
proliferate
and and keep the same so that is
what we envisioned throughout
and here also if you go from proteins to
genes
uh we have also in collaboration
together in protogenomic studies
mutation burdens where you look at
targeted mutations
and you can look that throughout the the
patient groups
and you can see to what frequency the
most
common uh genes are
mutated in different forms and this is
also a fingerprint
of of what's going on in a given study
we have spent a lot of time working
together with
pathology units and also for instance in
in
first department of pathology at the
tokyo medical hospital where we are
investigating the heterogeneity of of
how the tumors
present themselves and and the big that
this is really the big challenge because
there is a very broad window of of how
uh the morphology in a tumor looks
so you can have various degrees of
cancer cells different clones you can
see that they have different form and
shape of cells
you also have to you can also see that
the stromal component
it is important um in the
complexity of how tumors develop and
there are specific roles of
of the stromal part as well and then you
have the the infiltrating
lymphocytes as well that that takes part
in the action
that you can see in these tissues from
patients isolated so we reported this
just just recently in in a a major study
in um in cell biology and toxicology
and here i i put together with ishvan
a um an essay we developed for b ref
v600e that came out really really well
and and each one has a lead and is
really
professional in this area so on the left
hand side you see
a pretty homogenous expression
uh the brown color of bref when it's
mutated
and on the right hand side you see that
you have
on the upper image it's really only only
like
small islands of of of the brown
color that you see and that that is the
uh
the cancer cells where the b ref mutate
that the protein is is highly expressed
and in a magnification on the right hand
side on the lower
you see that there are small clones that
that look very different
uh within the in intra
heterogeneity example of of a
of a tissue isolated from from patient
so all of these
we do in in a very structured way
and we have developed a massive
investment in biobanking when
here you see henrietta who is the head
of the biobank team
and we have everything
barcoded we have software to drive
everything we have electronic
surveillance of
all the steps we do and we'll then link
these features to to the data generation
so that's the molecular pathology as we
identified
and uh here you see the the um the
iconic
automated biobank fully robotics at -80
it's a really impressive
uh capacity of almost 6 million
samples and then now we are approaching
2 million samples at this stage
and from here
we really make more and more
investigations of uh proteogen
how proteins and genes uh express
uh in tumors and we are particularly
interested also
in drug intervention and the impact of
drugs
what happens so we look at immunotherapy
we look at targeted therapy usually it's
uh it's b-ref
and then also chemotherapy in some cases
and of interest here of course
is a modification of proteins that
relates to a certain signaling cascade
can be specific for phosphocytes and
and also the entire set of kinases we
sort of reached out now and also we're
interested in
how we can see differences in between
expression
um when you build up a drug resistance
so all of this is in order to
to more understand the mechanism uh that
is actually not very well
understood today so this is
a lot of the the focus right now that we
are
together with the nih team and the test
and sort of pushing
and also within this uh
collaborative partnership and here is an
example
on this slide where you have the the
the transcript expression uh in
correlation with the uh
with the protein expression and in this
case it's uh
a study where we did like 100 patients
the crossover here
is like almost around 40
and there has been protogenomic studies
in different cancers published where you
currently there are data from 22 up to
60 percent
so around 40 percent is is pretty good
okay so um we did in this study also
uh an observation and a computation
uh resulting outcome that i think is
really exciting and that is that we
could
use the the clinical uh data
uh so the metadata from from the clinic
in order to divide and
and cluster all the data we generated in
the study
uh so that we were able to
divide these in three groups
so one group based upon the protein
expression we could identify
uh to be long survival uh
medium survival and short survivor so we
did find
25 proteins that associated to the
ability to distinguish
in between uh the outcome of the patient
and um we d we then selected
where we had a borderline of of 15
percent tumor at least that
you need to have so that is that is what
we
encountered in this study that we call
primero
okay so um now looking at
proteins having the the the clinical
material and
in terms of tissue uh well
imaging i mean looking into what you
really can
can envision in in a tissue by uh
moldy imaging um on the left-hand side
on this
presentation you can see that you have
tissue where you can divide it in by
histology the different parts
and what i found extremely exciting was
that we are now
able to determine based upon the
expression
in this different region within this
um tumor exemplified here
to give a certain
fingerprint that is designed for the
different parts so for tumor cells for
lymphocytes
connective tissue that can be can be
investigated so this is something that i
think
will have a a important
future bearing we also have
uh unatan eriksson who's a phd student
in our group that has done a really nice
development of
of software uh cluster-wide peak
detection
methodology whereby you can see here you
can go in and you can investigate
an histology site here
where you then actually can map that in
a raster set
and like a bar code you can then get
very very high resolution
so if you look to the to the masses
and the differences of the masses that
that
you can do by this software development
is really impressive
and we also did another um
application here where we had a
melanoma tumor development late stage
in a patient within the lung pulmonary
tract
uh isolated surgically and then we
look for the vemma phenib uh that is the
targeted drug uh binding the
the b ref and thereby blocking the the
the tumor growth and here you see uh
images that with the beginning with with
a
very very high resolution of masses so
this is an example where
you can actually localize specifically
where the drug
is is is located and where it ends up
so the question you're asking here does
really the drug uh hit
the the the tumor cells and where you
have a mutation
uh of the b ref yes or no so and the
special spatial resolution is like a
single cell
that you can make now um we also have
another uh study example i wanted to
show you
where you really can do duty mining
and and um in this
study with the mm-500 as you can see
on this slide here we really had uh have
collections from
a number of um metastases from different
uh organs and anatomic regions within
the body
uh of of patients that we have
um in collaborative effort uh with the
second and semi-wise
uh done and um the data here
are really extremely uh
detailed so here we did a um
a ranking of the proteins expressed
in melanoma according to abundance
so what you see here is actually the
the melanoma proteome so we believe that
we cover almost 16 000 here and we
believe that we have the majority
of all the players of proteins that have
a functional role to play within the
within the tumor biology
uh and many of these are mutated
and they're also dysregulated pathways
that have been investigated in quite
some detail
and then we also had a
done a study where we looked to
immunotherapy and there has been
data from us but also from other
scientific groups where we have been
able to to work
uh and look for proteins that are
regulated based upon treatment
and in a study we we picked out 25
proteins that we
had and then went through a high number
of patients in the
mm500 study actually 505
tumor samples where you can display
the impact of expression of these
another
study that we call cuato
is then something that we are very
excited about so this is a
a similar study where we are looking
into the
to the side where
and metastasis we also have a non-tumor
sample here and you can have tumor
microenvironments and you can
local recurrent
tissues and also cutaneous metastases
lymph nodes
and distant prostatitis so it's quite
quite a a
diverse presentation of
what you find as uh disease presentation
from patients and if you look here you
see
for the different type of of tissue
from this patient the expression
patterns for each and every one
of these samples so typically you get
something like 9000
proteins identified so this is a
non-labeled
uh approach that we do uh and this is
a a 90-minute gradient we run
and as you can see there are a lower
expression on the non-tumor side while
as these cells the cancers are activated
you see that
there is a a increase
in the proteins expressed in in these
tissues
now this slide here i think is is really
uh something that we are using now more
and more
so we have typically not been able
to always assist
statistically significantly prove
that we have a a change
of expression of of given proteins of
interest
and what we have done now is to use an
mcm complex
that is actually a complex link to the
dna
that is linked to to cell growth in a in
a
tumor proliferation and here
this mcm complex has six proteins
and they have are in stoichiometry one
two one
so what we did was to uh quantify these
six proteins and
and try to relate them to this
and then we also investigated uh because
uh
to a biomarker ki 67
that was uh first uh developed and and
and found by by a japanese team and we
related to ki 67
and here we were able actually to to
relate
primary tumors and metastasis
in a nice way to this mcm complex
expression
and we use that as the denominator uh in
order to
to see upon the upon the
expression so here you can see on the
left-hand side the green so
many of those are then uh lower
level of of turnover or proliferation
some of the metastases and and the
healthy of course
is in here and then on the right hand
side as
extreme as a very highly uh
proliferative
then you can see that primary tumor and
other type of metastases
are so we use this approach in order to
be able to
to to get more out of this and um mit
mitf is is a a
target protein that has a key role in in
the drive of of tumor development and we
could actually
find directly significance of regulation
both with and without the mcm complex
approach however the newly
presented ddx 3x gene that we
identify now on a protein level
published very recently in
cell we could find that
we couldn't directly get an upregulation
of the protein however
if we were related instead to the mcm
complex then we actually could find
significance so this is
a play of how you can develop other ways
of
variables being introduced using
proteomics here is another example that
i took where
you can see that bref and res
and and kit they are key players
in in patient tumors and and here
we are establishing now the correlation
in between these protein
abundances and mutation status in order
to try to understand the mechanism
whereby these are are are regulated and
mutated
and um we are now establishing a
database for this as well
uh in order to to get more detail so
this is something that we are
moving into in more depth so in
conclusion i would say that
um we have been
working for quite some time now over a
number of years
where we very often come from a healthy
status
on the upper left here of a patient that
somehow
enters into an early stage of disease
development in melanoma
and then what happens is that you you
get some some sort of
development of a tumor and and in this
case
we actually have a clinical metadata
so we follow the patients over
uh the entire period that they
are visiting the hospital and they are
very dedicated
and they are very eager to to provide
sample
so that works very well for us we do
this mostly in southern sweden now
so from early indication to to to until
the patient
pass away we have a number of samples
if there is a surgery involved we get
the tissue also
if there is no surgery but a checkup or
visit to the clinician we always get a
blood samples that are taken and in our
workflow routine in the biobank we
uh store the sample into minus 80
within two hours so that's the the
default
system that we run and then also we do a
lot
under now on
sequencing transcripts mostly we also
do protein analysis that i showed you
examples from
acetylation phosphorylation methylation
modification based upon treatment but
also
and then try to get more and more
information
with computation in signaling pathway
cascade to try to understand
what happens during the disease
development and when you add a drug and
you have
an effect by the drug how does that
actually change the tumor
and what happens with the patient and
and i would also like to
to um to give credit to
uh to um
uh both marcel and ishvana and the
pathology team and
the clinics who are doing a fantastic
job in really characterizing
uh all the the tumor material that we
work with and
we as as not i mean
medics most of us but we have uh six
uh md's within our team uh most
but we learn all the time and i think
that's very important in order to
increase the
the understanding so from here i
i conclude but uh i would like to to
just uh
remind you that in sweden we are
welcoming you
to yupo 2021 so 2020 was expected for
stockholm
but um you know kovit came in in between
here
so we we run that now as a
virtual meeting and then we will follow
up and have you
uh visiting stockholm hopefully uh for
next year
and the reason you should come is also
because
sweden and stockholm of course is a
fantastic place but it's because we also
have now
um a theme where we really
want to make a difference this time and
try to build
uh more towards the treatment
and some of the the areas we will focus
on you see in this slide
but also it's really the the disease
understanding
and also with the treatment and also
what technology
can do for us and it is we
we call this now that the clinical
proteomics for the benefits of the
patients
and we we feel very strongly for this
and we
welcome you to participate
so of course it's uh very important to
to
give also the uh our partners and the
funding bodies who provide resources so
that we can
do what we are best at and um
i would in particular like to to to
thank the um
ikea that has been extremely supported
throughout
a number of years ever since the nine
years that i
i left dusters and i can and i came to
the clinic and and to the university
here
um and then also um nih
uh nci the team over there and bethesda
that i think
are extremely important to us in order
to guide us and also to
to keep us really on the front and push
forward
and and um thermo
i i would like not because i give the
talk here because i think that they have
participated not only by having you know
instruments and development but actually
listening
and also being part of our build and
being interested and also being pushing
so i i value that a lot and visits to uh
to san jose every year once or twice in
order to brainstorm i i think that is
really extremely valuable iconic
instruments they have been
extremely supportive on the biobank side
we would never manage without
the the team of of less corpse i think
it's really
important so university and others so
um the healthcare sector vegan scale in
sweden uh
are of course of importance so we are
very active on social media
and here you see myself and you and in
the clinic when we
visited for a week uh before the coffee
came
last year uh we spent in in surgery and
in the hospital in sega
and with that i would like to
finish off and thank you for your
attendance and
i will be happy to take questions qa
later on
thank you very much
thank you so much professor marco vargas
uh it's been
been regaling us with a great
presentation
uh something to mention is that the
audience can submit
questions in the q a box so please we
invite you
and we have already received a number of
questions
so um
material practically you go about
optimum such
high quality samples and what defines
the high quality sample which
processes do you have
well thank you i think
and do it well is by collaborating
so i think our experience is that you
need to team up
uh with the healthcare sector
and if you do that in your own country
or if you collaborate like in in the
case of of the european cancer moonshot
clearly this is europe but we also have
links to the us japan and korea
and different countries have different
legislations they have different way
however what is common
is the overall who regulation and
guidelines
and i think also nih plays an important
role here
so i think only by by teaming up
and also by learning so you need to
reach out you need to interact i think
you need to
participate in in the society of
scientists but
try to to to change gears toward the
healthcare sector i think that's the
main important part that we have done
so close collaboration with the medics
with the healthcare healthcare providers
directly staying close to the patient
i think that's very nicely exemplified
in your presentation
and because you have mentioned
legislation
um what would be um
what what would be the context the
legislative effects to operate
so let's say what kind of uh ethics
permits and allowances would need to be
uh
closely considered implemented within
the context of
clinical theology
yeah i mean this is extremely important
it's also actually a lot of
administration which is a burden
but i do believe that um i mean you have
the biobank law
in the european union you have
bbmri as an organization in in brussels
that actually keeps all the member
states together
and they work out the procedures
together
so it's always based upon ethical basis
and don't forget that you know
in the end of the day the patient
will be the owner of the samples
and the patient is also owner of all the
data
generated doesn't matter if it's uh
pathology i mean histological reporting
or if it's
proteomics data whatever type of data it
is
the patient in the end will will be the
the key person
so one way of course is is to keep up
with that
um when you go to uh north america
you have other things that you you need
to
think about and care about if you go to
asia like um
south korea japan china as well
they will never ever allow any sample to
leave the country
and that's the case now in in additional
states
however in in scandinavia we when also
europe we are mostly active this is not
a problem
so you can do that but i think that you
need to align
um to a central apart and also now the
integrity of the patient and the patient
material
and the data generated with the new
regulations now with pdgr is very
important so that
you need to keep a strong eye on that
then you
actually you need persons who takes care
of it so if you run a bigger operation
like i showed you i mean i have seven
science and people in my biobank team
and they are responsible to keep up and
all the
old steps that has that does include
samples need to be electronically
surveyed
so you need to track need to be
trackable everything you do
attract samples track changes track
protein signatures that you are
referencing to in your in your
presentation
so you mentioned um protein expression
so that
is in regards to protein expression you
mentioned
27 proteins being associated with long
medium or short-term survival
um looking within melanoma
are these proteins specific
would you say for melanoma-associated
mechanisms
or it are they representative of a
broader possibly broader type of
oncology
that's actually a very that's that's a
tricky one now
and the answer the answer is that it's
um it's broader so it's not only
specifically uh proteins that are
associated
with with the tumor developments in
melanoma
it's also other generals so inflammatory
markers and other
proteins that are regulated so in this
primero study that we published this is
a pretty narrow
[Music]
class of patients so here we have
collected this is a swedish cohort
with uh metastasis so
in here we actually could find that and
you can
also we did blind test so you can
clearly see the
which group the patient
belongs to whether they will have longer
survival
or shorter
yes uh thank you and um
another question again oriented towards
protein
how can you get reproducibility
in the cancer studies and its
reproducibility
correlating to samples so sample
dependence somehow
so teachers in your case or extrapolated
towards
uh other types of biopsies or body
fluids
but from your experience
yeah well i mean i think that
the last years have been extremely
quickly developing in terms of of
let's say quality of data and that is
technology
uh driven so right now i mean you can do
studies with uh tmt
approaches or even a non-label
where the where the narrowness of the
expression and we are talking about
um high numbers are extremely good
so that part i think has been taking a
major
development so it's not like in the old
days you get
you know one sample from the other and
you run it in between days
so within day performance but also in
between that i think
is is very very good um
yeah okay so the type of sample i mean
if you compare for instance blood with
with tissue
um in in blood you have like 10 11
orders of magnitude expression
so that is really challenging
and there is a lot of development on
that area
so that has to take specific
considerations when it comes to tissue
i think the the type of tissue
will also determine uh the sample
preparation
part and i would say that the key
is is on that front line if you if
you're able to solubilize
into a liquid to any tissue material
you're probably okay um if you take for
instance
pancreatic cancer that is
probably one of the highest
stromal containing so connective tissue
containing
tumor type that is very very difficult
to get all of it solubilized
it's a challenge so it depends on which
tissue ties soft tissue is usually
easier
while others are more tricky
now when it comes to expression then you
also find that
dependent on on the compartment
of the tumor that you work with will
also determine
how well if it's a lot of repeat of
proteins and you have the more
narrow expression or if you are the
wider where you have
infiltrating leukocytes you have stromal
you have
different many clones of of cancer cells
within the tumor
that will also give a spread but i would
say in
in general now we are running
also other like in lung cancer studies
now i would say that
even with paraffin blocks
we are able to get very high
reproducibility
so i think we actually may have
performed a milestone now
also on the paraffin side so we are
doing like hundreds of of tumors that we
never have been able to do before and we
can do
it didn't show data today but we can do
a phosphor speciation on that so that's
that's another area
where you can sort of link the drug
impact and the signaling
and thank you for this very detailed
response
photo speciation is something that we
will
listen in the second part of the webinar
so maybe before before taking a short
break of half an hour
we would have time for one concluding
question
and that is in relation to how could
protein atlas
be used for clinical purposes
for treatment of cancer patients or
diagnostic purposes
well i i you know i think that the
proteomics field perhaps
without really knowing it or sort of
realizing it
has the power in their hands i think we
are there
actually and i think that
you as let's say instrumental providers
and technology provider
you have a big responsibility because i
believe that we
we actually got there so the protein
as a functional component
within healthcare for
being able to to get the right reporting
on a
stage of disease development
or which type of drugs we should use or
how we should treat the patient patient
that is
extremely difficult uh decisions for a
clinician to make
and i'm convinced uh that we will be
able to use proteomics
to provide tools to make it better
so professor thank you once again
and uh i'm looking forward to having you
join the roundtable discussion
so for our audience thank you for
joining
us and now we have a half an hour break
please take a q a team and do join us
in half an hour when we have a list of
outstanding speaker continuing with
presentations on the topic of
cancer challenges and analytics to help
us resolve
biology so thank you and
see you in the next session